- It's the first of the month.
You know what that means:
Rent’s due.
- [Offscreen voice 1:] Oh, my God! [Laughing]
- [Offscreen voice 2:] Oh, wow.
- [Offscreen voice 3:] Thank you.
- [Offscreen voice 2:] Thank you so much.
- What's up, guys?
I'm Tyrann Mathieu, also
known as The Landlord.
They call me The Landlord
cuz I own the field and I take care of
Chiefs kingdom, but right now my social
responsibility goes much beyond that.
A lot of people have been
impacted by COVID-19, especially
in my hometown of New Orleans.
I'm hoping to find a few families
that I can really impact
and help and love and support.
I'm looking forward to checking them out.
- Hi, Tyrann.
My name's Sarah Jane, and I'm a
unit director here at the Boys &
Girls Clubs of Southeast Louisiana.
And I'd love to introduce you to
one of our families that's been
affected by the COVID-19 virus.
We've got Marcus, one
of our youngest members, and his mother,
Torri, who is a health care worker who has
recently gotten off of quarantine due
to exhibiting symptoms with the virus.
Um, they're an amazing family to
have with us, and I'd love for
you to get to know them more.
- Hey. Can you hear me?
- Hi, Tyrann. How you doing?
- Hey! How you doing?
- I can’t complain. I can’t complain.
- I've heard so many great things
about you and your son, Marcus.
- I hope that he’s doing well.
- Yes. Yes. Correct.
- Yeah.
Also, I've heard that you, that
you've recently recovered from COVID-19.
- Yes.
- I’m so happy to hear that.
Um, I have a brother actually that's
a registered nurse, so I'm so grateful
for you being on the front line,
um, and for all that you do.
Um, and I'm so happy that you're
back working too.
- I'm excited too.
Trust me, the people I work for, they were excited too.
- [Offscreen voice:] Yes, we were.
- You heard my boss just said that?
[All laughing]
- So, hey, can I ask you, like, how was
it, how was it dealing with the, having
those symptoms and not being able to work?
How was that?
- It was lonely.
That was, I think that was the most
difficult part, was being by myself.
I don't think I would ever want
anybody to have to experience that.
Cuz you're basically,
you know, by yourself, just
hoping and praying everything
turns out well, you know?
- I'm so glad
that you, that you was able to recover
from that and that you seem to be in
great spirits right now, and that's
always a positive and, uh, I'm sure,
I'm sure Marcus, you know, was
there for you and I'm—so I don't want
you to ever feel like you're alone.
Um, I want you to know that
I'm always with you too.
- I appreciate that. I appreciate that, Tyrann.
You are awesome.
I have watched you
since high school at St. Augustine.
- Aww.
- I’ve followed your career.
So I want you to know that I have
rooted for you for a long time.
I watched you go through your own trials
and tribulations, and I'm proud of you.
I'm happy for you.
And for me to see you win, that
made me feel like home wins too.
You know?
- Yes, ma'am.
I appreciate you so much.
Hey, so I know Marcus is living
with his dad currently right now, right?
- Yeah.
That's Marcus.
- How has
it been having him away?
- It has been difficult. Marcus is
my last little child.
My other kids are
adults, so, trust me, it's been—I miss him. I miss him.
- I bet.
So I want to get personal
with you for just a moment.
Uh, how was, how was the,
how was it financially for
you, not being able to work?
- Um, I'm basically trying to
recuperate from this situation.
Normally, I'm able to go in and
work extra hours and stuff like that.
But, um, because I do normally
take care of one lady at her house,
to prevent from anything being,
you know, impeding upon her,
I have to take that into consideration.
- You know my nickname is
The Landlord, uh, cuz, cuz, you
know, I take care of the field and,
uh, I take care of the kingdom too.
And you deserve so much more, you
know, being a front-line worker, um,
you know, representing my hometown.
Uh, you know, like I mentioned earlier,
my brother is a registered nurse as well.
So I have, I have so much respect
for you guys and everything that
y'all do, everything y’all sacrifice,
um, to really protect us.
Um, but, but I want you to
check your phone right now.
I want you to check your
texts for me, please, if you could.
- You are awesome.
I kid you not. This has been really awesome.
- I've sent you one month’s rent,
and then my friends at Zelle, they're
actually gonna donate and match me.
So you're actually going to be covered
for two months. Check your account
once we hang up, and it should be there.
- Just to have this conversation
with you was rewarding for me.
Thank you.
I'm so grateful.
I appreciate the donation.
I'm, I’m grateful.
I am.
I'm grateful.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
And you take care,
OK?
- I will.
You too.
And I'm gonna be watching you when
you do get to go back on the field, now.
- I got you.
Thank you so much.
- All right.
Thank you.